students attending the columbia grammar
and preparatory school in manhattan this
is a very expensive school i think it
costs just shy of 50
gs a year to attend
they are being forced to take
an explicit class on porn
without parental consent
would be bad enough to force them to
take the class on porn they're not even
telling the parents
echoing sorts of things we've heard a
lot this year where radical educators
will say hey
be careful the problem with zoom class
is the parents will know what's being
taught you got to be very careful
don't you think the parents maybe should
know what's being taught no it's very
bad very bad for their education
so at this school they were teaching a
very explicit porn class and i'm not
just saying like
the birds and the bees and look at this
and look at this flesh mashing up
against this flesh
talking about like very i'm not going to
say it on the show this is a family
program
but but but really graphic gross
stuff the class involved a slideshow and
a lecture by an instructure
which included lots of raunchy images
lots of presentations on the most lord
porn genres
and only fans which is the
democratization of porn
and if you oppose this sort of thing you
will be called close-minded oh come on
you're just a prude
you're you're a prude come on that's
fine what could go wrong with porn well
we're hearing what goes wrong with porn
how many people right into this i've
read them in the mail bag people write
in all the time
and say we got to do something about
porn this is really bad stuff
do you know who's writing it's not the
old fuddy daddy's writing in it's not
the boomers the boomers
seem to be the ones who are most fine
with porn they say oh it's not a big
deal
they tend to fall a little more in that
squish libertarian camp
oh come on it's not come on every
looking at porn that's as american as
apple pie it's protected by the first
amendment it's not a big deal
but the people who write into me and say
this is a big deal or the young men who
get
hooked on this stuff i think the median
age is something like 11
according to surveys so they get hooked
on this stuff before they can
know anything about it it ruins their
lives they it messes up their
relationships
it hurts women obviously the industry
hurts women but the just even the kind
of
vision of sex that it presents is very
degrading toward women messes up
people's relationships
there's a epidemic of young men who
who have ed because they're hooked on
porn
they're certain that's not you used to
just read about these stories in japan
apparently this has come to the west
as well it's really really bad stuff
why would that be taught in schools oh
come on keep an open mind
obviously we used to know this in this
country but now we've forgotten it
liberty and licentiousness are not the
same thing they're opposite things if
you arouse people's
vices and base passions you're going to
undermine their true liberty
kick it out fire teachers who push this
not don't just vote with your dollars
vote with your politics use your
government
get this stuff take a lesson from
desantis desantis knows what's up
pay attention to this stuff and kick it
out
porn has become in a certain sense it's
become part of the liturgy of
liberalism that there's and i won't get
into too graphic
detail of what these liturgical
practices look like but it really has
sort of become part of it it is
something that one enacts it is
considered good do you remember at the
start of covid when people were told
they couldn't see one another
the new york city health department
encouraged people to um
how do i put this to use woody allen's
term to have sex with someone you love
you know
alone in a room and this was being
encouraged this is a good thing it's
good for your health blow off a little
steam
i've heard this described that in in
historically speaking our views of the
mind
tend to map on to our views of
technology so when the printing press
was big we had this view that
what was being imprinted on your mind
that's that's going to form your mind to
some degree that's true
when the steam engine was the big
technology we were told you had freud
right you had this idea that you have to
stop
repressing things you need to let off a
little bit of steam right
and to a lesser degree that that's not
quite true now today our view of the
mind is that the mind is like a computer
because the computer is the main
technology so you should be able to
upload things and download things and
also
upgrade your your mind or something like
that
okay i understand all these various
theories of the mind
when you blow off a little steam with
something like porn you know if you get
when you forget even just porn for a
second with any kind of vice if you
think that if you
commit a vice that's going to blow off a
little steam that's not really how it
works
the more advice you commit the more
you're going to commit the more virtue
you practice the more you're going to
practice that's the way it works we've
known this since good old uncle
aristotle but we seem to have forgotten
it the purpose of education liberal
education is to train yourself
in that liberty so do it any education
that undermines that
is the sort of thing you got to boot out
of the classroom
all right now that i've got your
attention ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe
like make sure that you get the
notifications while you're at it by the
way
head off of youtube and go on over to
our podcast apps you know apple podcast
spotify or
google play wherever you listen to your
podcasts make sure you subscribe
we've heard there's some shenanigans
going on with our subscriptions
and our our shows on those apps so just
just to make sure that there's no
glitches or anything like that head on
over subscribe if you wouldn't mind
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you